did you know that there are a number of
Dragon Ball Z episodes that are
literally film level quality and I'm not
talking about animation when I say that
back in the day anime was made
photographing physical cells on the same
kind of film that movies were shot on
but film comes in different sizes bigger
pieces of film means it's easier to
capture higher quality scans and well
Dragon Ball Z was shot on 16 millimeter
but there's a few episodes that actually
used 35 millimeter film that's right
over double the clarity of the other
episodes and if you look at those
episodes in Dragon Ball Kai the only
existing HD material using the original
35 millimeter Masters for these episodes
you'll see it's in insanely crisp
compared to the rest unfortunately Kai
Remains the only way that you can see
these on the DVDs they weren't handled
properly so they actually look worse
than the 16 millimeter episodes and as
far as funimations Blu-rays go those
things were made using secondary Masters
that were only 16 millimeter two
defeating the whole point of the amazing
sharpness